ça fait maintenant plusieurs semaines
que les parisiens n'en reviennent pas
lionel messi c'est une des plus grandes
stars de l'histoire du foot elle est au
psg c'est magnifique alors depuis c'est
une bonne info bernard
[Applaudissements]
raison de manioc s'envole oui voilà et
continue de construire son empire
financier à paris ils cherchent
maintenant où habitait paris damman il
va pas habiter dans un petit studio à
regarder
[Musique]
mais non quand on parle football on
parle surtout du transfert de l'année
l'arrivée de lionel messi au psg une
arrivée d'un des meilleurs joueurs au
monde qui fait aujourd'hui autant parler
pour son jeu de jambes que pour son
compte en banque le paris saint germain
a dû casser sa tirelire plus de 40
millions d'euros de salaire net annuel
il faut dire que les footballeurs sont
parmi les personnalités les mieux payés
au monde alors forcément avec un tel
transfert les chiffres atteignent des
sommets et qui dit déménagement d'une
nouvelle maison s'installer paisiblement
à paris messi et les siens auraient des
vues sur une villa pour la - cosy une
petite merveille qui coûterait la
bagatelle de 48 millions d'euros il faut
dire qu'on parle d'un palais situé dans
le vésinet à côté de paris de 2000 m²
pour le logement principal est de 500
mètres carrés supplémentaires pour
accueillir les proches dans la guest
house et soyons honnêtes le nail a de
quoi voir venir avec son arrivée au psg
le joueur argentin toucherait cent
treize mille euros par jour soit un
salaire mensuel de 3,4 millions d'euros
nets avec un contrat de deux ans plus
une année optionnelle il y à fort à
parier que l'agent immobilier devrait
accepter son dossier sans rechigner
est ce qu'elle est choquée par et non
mais sirigu à vendre donc il n'achètera
jamais
[Rires]
gilles est choqué oui quand même parce
que les sommes sont folles alors je
voudrais juste vous donner une info sur
la manière dont les footballeurs
étrangers comme messi négocié leurs
salaires en france près quand on dit
n'être c'est double nettes c'est à dire
que c'est le net social on enlève les
charges et le net fiscal ouais ils sont
terrorisés par le fisc en france les
équipes du psg calcule combien les armes
on va leur prendre et messi dit moi je
me moque totalement de vos impôts je
veux savoir combien seraient dans la
poche à la fin de la saison et donc le
salaire brut et monumental et moi quand
je vois le palais
hypersécurisée luxueux là au jour
d'aujourd'hui je sais que ça peut
paraître démagogique mais oui ça me
choque c'est dépaysant un fabuleux
logique c'est démago
franchement
une beuverie évidemment une maison à 48
millions d'euros c'est énorme et c'est
en phase avec ses revenus il est
milliardaire messi fait partie des rares
sportifs qui sont milliardaires à
barcelone y avait une plus petite villa
qu'il avait acheté 2 millions d'euros
qui en vaut 10 millions aujourd'hui là
c'est en phase avec ses revenus en
attendant il était logé dans une suite
d'un grand hôtel à 17000 euros la nuit
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui comprenne pas
choquant par exemple banon bien c'est le
groupe est détenu par le psg c'est le
groupe hôtelier faty sponsors qui se
montrent ceaurriz le psg donc cédé
chambre des lords y attardons un tarif
préférentiel et voilà c'est quelqu'un
qui de toute façon est complètement hors
sol donc c'est plus rien de choquant
pour messi est dans le panorama de lutte
et donc elle a mal joué hier parce qu'il
s'adaptait ouais c'est choquant qu'elle
aimait chatel a
en fait il rapporte beaucoup donc et
gagner beaucoup et tant mieux s'ils le
dépensent a fait tourner l'économie s'il
y avait quelqu'un de tellement riche qui
ne dépensait pas eh bien personne en
profiterait donc
y'a qu'en france on cherche un quart aux
états unis un sportif qui aime beaucoup
ça choquera personne qu'il est une belle
a raison mais c'est pas mal car c'est
d'abord la population et
bah non il ya des pauvres aussi
mais beaucoup plus importante donc les
enjeux sont plus importants et les
cachets des publicitaires sont pas
beaucoup aimé ça je m'énerve les
chiffres de geci regarder les chiffres
2006 et celle ci ne les verras c'est ne
pas arriver normalement ça y est
abaissée là oui oui celle à 38 millions
reversés la sécurité c'est pas mal hein
10 millions versés trésor public mais
c'est bien ça il fait gagner 50 millions
à l'état français bah oui c'est pas mal
ça que des maillots ils génèrent venez
regarder la vente des maillots il
dépasse plus de 50 % celle de neymar ah
oui ça c'est marrant ça quand même et il
a fait augmenter de 20% les abonnements
sur les réseaux sociaux du club je le
lis parce que certains ici de
s'interdire
de le faire d'accord mais c'est anormal
des eaux qui fait exploser davantage que
messi les réseaux sociaux quand tes
posts un message ou quand ils signent
quelque part voilà c'est les deux
joueurs ils sont les plus grandes stars
actuelles vote